I want to talk about last man on earth
it is one of my favorite shows it's
absolutely hilarious it's genius I love
it you shoot that show in Chatsworth is
that right yeah is that a fun place to
be shooting Chatsworth California it's
pretty fun it's the porn capital of the
world
it started as as that that's like the
backdrop for a Billy Knights I think yes
it's where they shot all of the original
porn movies from what like the 60s 70s
80s yeah and it definitely smells like
it and our studio is it's kind of
sandwiched between two working dildo
factories a joke no one of them's called
pipe dreams right I don't know the other
one is called but I want to call it like
forever boyfriend yeah so you're serious
they are churning out these factories on
either side of where you guys shoot last
man on earth they are churning out dildo
yeah I don't make stuff up okay okay
make them fast enough
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
I don't want a day-old dull dark old
dildo trust me
I also like picturing like a conveyor
belt just dumping them into an open
truck like their oranges and then a
really sweet man I'm gonna go the same
guy that made the pizza market paper
boys throwing them into people's long
[Applause]
yeah we can dream we start dreaming we
died when we stopped sounded like you
said when you start I might have said
beau that would have been a slip tell me
start dreaming we die Oh what's wrong
with Onan all right I told you not to
mention